[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Sathyan we
are gonna be having a thoughts on
episode on time and attention one of the
most valuable things for us to talk
about in our lives let's take a moment
to just sing into our bodies with breath
into our hearts time attention such a
valuable commodity if not the most
valuable commodity today it's being
manipulated harder than ever
technology is growing faster than human
wisdom for how to manage it all right
you're born you get about two and a half
billion seconds or heartbeats to live
that's about 80 years or so that's also
about 25,000 days 2 and 1/2 billion
second / heartbeats 25,000 days a third
of these days you're gonna spend
sleeping a third of the days you're
gonna spend working and hopefully
building something that you love and a
third you're gonna spend doing what you
want so you get about 8,000 days to do
what you want that is a very short time
to live we're blessed with the
opportunity to be alive on this earth
with the civilization that people have
built but it is a very short ride and it
used to be even shorter so with that
time that we actually have in the short
amount of time and days that we have to
live where is our attention focused out
of the seven and a half billion people
that are alive today you get about 16
waking hours per day eight you spend
sleeping on a 20
for us to get 16:08 sixteen times seven
and a half billion is a hundred and
twenty billion collective human
attention hours on the planet per day
it's a zero-sum game this cake isn't
growing so it's 120 billion human
attention hours and the cake stays the
same so when I take a larger piece of
cake right now that you're watching this
space book or Instagram or someone else
is losing your attention so the fact
that I'm taking a large piece of cake
means they're getting a smaller piece of
cake some other content creator loses
the attention when someone else takes
the attention this is how it works we
need to explore ways of augmenting this
also the neural architecture that we
have is limited real estate so when
you're born you you get a certain amount
of time to fill your brain with certain
experiences and activities that will
hopefully maximize your soul path your
blueprint for life and your divinity
what you want to achieve in this world
so you've got to be really really
careful about what you choose to fit
into your neural real estate what you
choose to spend your time and your
attention on so you fill it in with
knowledge that actualizes you and
transcends the you is crucial to do and
we got to provide an equality of
opportunity for everybody on the planet
to be able to play with tools and
resources to figure out what actually
actualizes them when we used to be awake
during the day a hundred years ago
nobody could ping us then phones came
alive and people could ping you on the
phone then the internet happened people
could pay you on the internet and now we
have these computers and our pockets
that we check a hundred and fifty times
per day a hundred and fifty times per
day we're checking the [ __ ]
it's crazy do you think that da Vinci
could have invented with the smartphone
do you think that Michelangelo could
have sculpted the Statue of David or
painted the Sistine Chapel with a
smartphone how many times would have
they got distracted these are really
good compared
for us to really think about how we
gotta focus our energy and our time into
building things that bring value and not
get side railed and vectored off of our
soul path by these notifications that
are usually meaningless building a
business and making an impact on the
world is not instant gratification we
have to stop treating it as such it
takes time effort suffering tears
dedication perseverance
and then successes happen over time and
meaning comes from enjoying the journey
each moment along the way sure the world
is at our fingertips now to gain
whatever knowledge we want when we want
and something like engineering has been
democratized through educational videos
teaching us how to build that's
fantastic
but at what cost how many people use
technology to gain knowledge versus
Vector themselves off their sole path
for short-term dopaminergic hijacking of
their brain it's so tempting to get
notifications and to want to go read and
want to go look but how many of them are
actually useful for your sole path why
does our attention gravitate to just one
more video or just a couple more Scrolls
on news feeds that are algorithmically
made to be echo chambers to keep us
hooked on what we already like not
challenging our viewpoints it's because
of cognitive ease it's much harder for
us to go and work on our project to do
creative thinking than it is to just
scroll on a newsfeed and consume
creation is harder than consumption
relaxing the soul from the hard work
we've been doing sure yeah that's right
we can consume when we want to relax
from the hard work but how often do we
put our side are conscientious contracts
that we've made to achieve our goals
that we set up to execute in order for
our attention to be hijacked by
something else
corporations are aiming to be in more
control of our attention than we are we
must be more in control we must be more
vigilant when I get on my phone I use it
how I want to you
not how a corporation wants me to use it
so they can maximize their shareholder
returns when I see myself pick up a
phone and all of a sudden I get pushed
notifications right away instantly
they're trying to lure me into their
attention economy they're trying to
strategically hijack my attention and
yes you can turn off all your app
notifications but we want to be kept in
the loop for the rare notifications that
are actually important for helping us
drive our goals corporations will be a
sneaky and manipulative as possible to
get your attention and keep you there so
that they can make money on you be
vigilant
don't let notifications vector you away
from your sole purpose rarely as a
notification meaningful enough for your
attention at that exact moment the
signal-to-noise ratio is so low right
now what you need to gather from social
media and news and video content is very
little amount of your time and you need
to customize it so that you don't see
the noise don't give these distracting
pieces of content or distracting
notifications your attention stay
focused keep building what you're
focused on don't let the attention
economy win these business models are
[ __ ]
how many would pay 10 bucks a month to
never see ads on Facebook to be able to
see your networking history or to be
able to customize your newsfeed more the
next iterations of Facebook will decide
if it stays alive or doesn't I feel it
will but only if it drastically augments
its design in favor of ethics and
customization and love and away from
attention economics towards helping
people with their sole purpose we must
design technology to help people with
their sole purpose and not to vector
them off their path to make money for
megalomaniacs that's horrible we haven't
even touched on the mental health piece
yet sure kids are using it today they
can send direct messages instantly to
people across the world
they can go learn that from the
engineering educational videos but they
also see the follower counts and they
want to become famous and sure they can
get motivated by things like this but
we're also creating massive anxiety and
social pressure for young kids
people are being psychometrically
profiled through their likes and their
habits and then internet propagandists
are playing deep fakes into their feeds
to inner rage them with the content
itself is fake sometimes completely fake
content and sometimes it's being
soundbite at for an arrangement
propagation and polarization be very
skeptical be very careful with your
attention look at more facts read more
and learn more and analyze more before
formulating opinions and stay
open-minded blockchain can greatly help
identify truthfully when someone is
actually saying something it's a very
exciting part about that technology
stack Makela maniacs want to own our
attention and time they want to feed ads
to us to make money
be skeptical be vigilant with your
attention and time and restructure the
system around ethics and sole purpose
how has this affected our culture the
Internet's at our fingertips for
knowledge great almost all of us are
feeding into the attention economy where
are we really happier than we were
before all this were we finding more
meaning in our lives before now were we
connecting more intimately and lovingly
with our communities families loved ones
really analyze all these variables and
think where we living more happy where
we living more connected where we living
more peaceful more loving more caring ly
before this or what aspects were what
aspects are not how do we maximize all
of the meaning and happiness with the
technology we have now all right so
remember some takeaways time and
attention are the most valuable
commodities be vigilant don't get
vectored off your soul path focus your
attention egg
cute your goals push for design ethics
and fix the business models around
attention economics thanks for tuning in
go create go build go and manifest your
destiny we have an epic event coming up
in San Francisco on November 15th where
we are gonna be talking about reclaiming
our minds from the social media economy
the attention economy and designing the
future of the ethics and the business
models around social media that events
gonna be in partnership of civility in
San Francisco on November 15th join us
there thank you everyone for tuning and
go create go build go manifest your
destiny much love peace
[Applause]
you
[Music]